hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game from the penultimate round
of the usgs championship 2021 it's the
leader alexander landerman versus
fabiano carwana who is trying to catch
up to the leaders we're not gonna
discuss anything um other than that
because the game there's just too much
to cover let's dive straight into it uh
slenderman with the white pieces opens
with uh d4 we have knight to f6 by fabi
c4 and g6 going for the king's indian
defense and now are you going to go for
knight to c3 but here we have g3
preparing to fianchetto the light square
bishop right away uh black does the same
uh of course now fianchettoing the
bishop and bishop to g2 we have d6 by
fabi and knight to c3 so this is all
very very standard stuff uh castles by
fabi and knight to f3 we have c6 and now
castles and here uh queen to a5 is still
the the most popular for black but fabi
goes for bishop to f5
an excellent square for the bishop here
you could chase it away right away with
some like knight to the h4
but here we have knight to g5 uh putting
more pressure on the e4 square and now
what do you do here well fabi plays e5
asking black do you want to capture an
e5 or do you want to advance the pawn of
course always the pawn is advanced here
so d5
and now you could play something like h6
you could play c5 5 you place a5 here
puts
well now prepares this knight to a6 jump
and then you will also have uh the b4
square uh controlled by your own pawns
you could play maybe knight a6 knights
to c5 and you don't have to worry about
this knight being kicked away with a
move like d4 because the d pawn is
already on d5 and of course b4 will not
be possible so uh there is there's that
we have e4 now chasing away the bishop
and there is a game in the database uh
from 2019 world cup uh between yumabayev
and berkshire where uh bishop
uh g4 was played in the white was able
to win that game but here we have bishop
to c8 by fabi and it is now as of move
10 that we have a completely new game
and this is basically where our game
begins so h3 uh by lenderman and now
fabi trades once we have c captures c
characters and the knight the a6 the
knight can now come to c5 like we said
uh bishop to e3 uh continuing
development and now bishop to d7 and now
we have a4 stopping any advancement with
a move like b5 that might be a bit too
strong for black so rook to c8 and now
comes knight back to f3
and
right at the moment when the knight
retreated to f3 uh one of the defenders
from the e4 pawn has been removed and
this is where fabi goes for it and this
is where fabi shows that he is uh very
very much interested in playing for the
win this game with the black pieces and
he starts uh by sacrificing the exchange
with rook captures on c3 b captures on
c3 and the knight captures on e4 so
something similar like you would have
maybe in the knight of sicilian
uh attacking the c3 pawn and now queen
to c2 and now knight eat the c5 getting
the knight out of harm's way yeah and
now there's the weak c3 pawn so of
course we might have some ideas of
doubling up on the c file we're down the
exchange but unless white really makes
his rooks uh come alive we don't really
mind we still have the knight pair and
the bishop pair so knight to d2
and
queen to c7 preparing to bring more
firepower maybe to the to the c8 but
also the rook could be coming to e8 you
might also leave the rook on uh f8 maybe
play f5 f4 so many options here so rook
to a3 uh getting the rook away from the
a1 square makes sense and also you add a
defender here to the uh to the c3 pawn
so f5 by black and now uh f4 of course
we do not want to allow black to play f4
because then the bishops really come
alive so f4 and now uh what do you play
here well a very interesting idea for
fabi is b5
uh yeah and also notice how uh when favi
sacrificed the rook with sacrifice the
exchange with rook captures on c3 uh
white lost the b pawn so white can never
play b4 ever again in this game uh so
here uh if i play rook to a8 but b5 is
very very interesting point is after
eight captures and bishop captures
attacking the rook we're going to play
c4 strengthen our center and attack the
bishop here knight to b for attacking
the queen and now queen back to d1 and
here for example e captures an f4 and we
have a completely crazy position here
something like bishop captures bishop a6
and who who who can really say what's
happening here so yeah this is possible
uh but fabi goes for rook to e8 first
puts more pressure on the e file now you
might have some ideas of captures
captures bringing the rook all the way
to e2 so here we have f captures on e5
bishop captures an e5 and now bishop
back to f2 guarding the g3 pawn uh and
only now fabi executes this d5 a b5 id
on the queen side so a captures on b5
bishop captures and now rook f2 a1 and
this is how white activates both of his
rooks and now black really has to figure
out how to how to counter all this power
on the on the a file he finds knight the
d3 and it comes with it there he's
saying okay capture my a5 pawn uh and
there's nothing wrong with this the the
idea is after rook captures on a5 we're
going to play knight a to b4 of course
the knight cannot be captured the queen
will be hanging but after queen to some
queen to b3 we're going to capture the
c3 pawn and then probably we have this
end game where white really shouldn't
have any problems he's up the exchange
black is up a pawn
but
white should never be worse but this is
a lot of activity fabi has here so if
the rook joins in for example with some
like rook to e2 could be very dangerous
so uh white uh decides against this he
plays queen to b1 puts pressure on the
bishop here but now knight a to b4 by
fabi
and now again a incredibly complicated
move what do you play here
should you capture the knight should you
capture the the pawn here with rook
captures on a5 well it's very
interesting for example if c captures uh
on b2 and b4 we're going to play knight
captures on f2 and you can't
touch this knight if you play king
captures an f2 just bishop to d4 check
and you're getting destroyed king has to
come to f3 bishop to check into f4 now
queen e7 with the g5 coming that's uh
just game so what you would have to do
after this knight captures on f2 idea is
to just go knight to f3 uh this uh allow
this means that now you have to give up
the g3 pawn and after bishop captures on
g3 is played uh again we have to be very
very careful we can't play a b captures
on a5 even though we really want to
create this pass pawn uh because queen
c5 and white can just uh pretty much
resign there's not much you can do here
uh
any uh
any knight move will be will be deadly
so you might free up your g2 square for
your king but still rook to e1
incredible stuff by black in this
position that never never actually
happened but you know i i felt obligated
to show this to you and now if of course
queen captures here 94 check uh picks up
the queen so beautiful stuff so you will
not be able to do this after bishop
captures on g3 there's no time for white
to play b captures on a5 white would
have to play bishop to f1 right away uh
but then of course we simply capture
bishop captures queen chapter 7 and now
play a capture some b4 now black having
the past pawn in this completely crazy
position uh that's uh probably a draw
but you know who knows and who would who
would have time to calculate all of this
out even in a classical game
so after knight eight to b4 uh we have
rook captures on a5 he doesn't go for
this absolute sharpest line we have rook
captures on a5 uh because in that line
it's not that he doesn't want to play it
it it's that he also does not have any
winning chances so here rook captures
and if i was played now queen captures
on c3 saying okay you capture my bishop
i'm going to capture the knight here so
bishop the e3 defending the knight
and now what do you play well bishop to
d4 now you could try a lot of things you
could try bishop captures on g3 that's
fine but bishop to d4 is just more more
um
you know
directed towards
what's actually happening uh so bishop
captures on the four queen captures on
d4 with check now king h2 and now of
course fabi has to continue the attack
with f4 so how do you counter this g4 of
course we do not want to capture this uh
and now comes rook to e2 another
another move where fabi has to allow
white to make progress in order for
himself to make progress because of
course you do not want to move the rook
here you could play something like queen
to f2 uh preparing rook to e2 but then
for example knight to f3 uh queen to g3
check king to g1 and knight f2 it seems
like it's deadly uh but it yields uh
only only a draw for example white will
happily capture on b5 he doesn't care
and after something like knight captures
an h3 check king h1 you might even play
knight the d3 saying okay if queen
captures knight f2 check picks up the
queen but we don't care just rook to b2
and that's it we we hold this position
nicely knight to f2 check we're going to
give up the rook knight captures with
czech king g1 and now whatever you can
just uh repeat for for something like
knight h3 with a repetition or knight
captures on g4 continue playing but
still it's not going to be more than
more than a draw so queen to f2 although
it seems like the the proper way to
continue uh there's no winning chances
here so uh rook to e2 was what fabi
chose uh and now rook to a8 with check
and here you have to be very very
careful if you start moving the king
king to g7 you are now dead lost a rook
a one to eight seven check king h6 now
g5 check and you can't pick up the pawn
because knight f3 check uh picks up the
queen so you'd have to go here but now
we just force you to pick up the pawn
rook captures an h7 checking captures
knight f3 check black loses uh the queen
and of course the game
so after rook eight rook to a8 check
fabi cannot start running away with the
king he has to play bishop to a8 uh e8
but it's fine because the bishop wasn't
really doing all that much on b5 if
anything it was only a target
and now queen to g1 offering a queen
trade which is definitely favorable for
white fabi has to avoid this he plays
queen to b2 now puts more pressure on
the knight here and knight to f3
defending and now uh how can fabi make
progress here well uh the rook can't
really move it has to keep uh uh
guarding that bishop on e8 so fabi plays
king to f8
uh makes sense now the king guards the
bishop and also you are in a dark square
your opponent has a light square bishop
so if anything a a more safer square for
the king we have rook 1 to a7 now really
cutting off that black king and
well what can fobby play here
uh fabi plays h6 he doesn't allow any
knights the g5 ideas for for the knight
to jump forward uh but here he also
allows a brilliant brilliant move um for
lenderman to play but it's a move not
everyone can find it's really a hard one
uh
just a beauty so feel free to pause the
video and try to find this move that
really gives white uh a lot of advantage
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh just you know completely stifling
positional idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it's g5 uh
this was not played in the game but i
will show you just how powerful the move
is uh you can't even dream of playing h5
here it's it's just not possible white
will just play rook capture 78 uh okay
let me do this a little bit slower rook
capture sun e8 with check and whatever
you do let's say this queen to b6 and
there's really no defense you are
getting checkmated here with the
recovering the entire seventh rank you
don't expect this position to blow up
like this but it was definitely in the
position and even if black was for
something like knight captures here
queen captures 97 blocking you're still
going to pick up this knight
and you're going to have a completely
winning position so after g5 of course
h5 is not happening you would have to
play h captures and g5 but now knight
captures on g5 and now well there are
all sorts of problems here for example
black's best bet is to go for something
like f3 but then we have rook to f7
check now the bishop of course cannot
move king g8 and now rook captures on f3
so queen to e5 check and now of course
we have to defend the knight rook to g3
and now knights to f4 and now it seems
like white is completely uh destroyed
here but uh there's really nothing
happening here you're gonna play queen
to a7 and it's a black who's gonna have
to fight for for survival here you're
gonna have to go for the forcing rook
captures on g2 rogue captures knight
captures with check now you don't want
to capture and allow queen captures and
g5 would check so you have to move the
king and now we're going to see
something like a queen to e1 check and
now of course we're going to block with
our own queen and uh well we know that
already that the end game is favorable
for us you don't really have a choice
here you have to trade queens you're
losing the knight for example king f8
we're gonna play king captures on g2 and
now there's nothing better than to trade
just captures captures and you get this
position where both players have two
pawns but white has a rook against a
bishop so white is much much better here
and this is definitely what was in the
position so g5
a remarkable move uh congratulations to
everyone who found this but rook to b7
is what was played in the game and this
allows fabi just enough time to
consolidate he plays knight to e5 and
now uh what do you play uh well of
course the thread is knight captures an
f3 check this will lose you the queen
because the bishop is pinned so king the
h1 unpinning and now knight captures on
f3 we have bishop captures and now rook
to e5 getting the rook out of harm's way
but also putting some pressure on that
d5 pawn
and also if the the position opens up
maybe you can even shift the rook over
to the to the king side uh so here you
have rook the c8 by white this was
white's last opportunity to go for queen
to a1 because the white really needs to
trade queens he's up the exchange and
this pretty much ensures a queen trade
because you have to keep an eye on this
knight here and there is no no good way
to do this for example if you play
something like queen d2 to keep an eye
on the knight you're we're just going to
play rook capture sunny e8 check rook
captures or king captures and queen to
a8 will be checkmate it doesn't really
matter uh or if you play rook captures
then the even more interesting queen to
g7 or queen to h8 checkmate so uh
a little trick that was definitely in
the position this queen to a1 really
forces things
but rook to see it is what was played
and now queen to d2 by fabi now you
don't have to worry about such things we
have rook to c1 now you have to
also help out with the defense of the
white king rook the e3 attacking the
bishop and rook to f1 and now all of a
sudden from that position where both
players were equally attacking equally
aggressive now we have this position
where fab is the one who's attacking
who's aggressive and landerman is the
one who's defending so knight to d3 now
the knight can come to e5 to put more
pressure on the f3 square
and g4 and now queen g2 offering a queen
trade but now fabio of course will not
uh accept queen to c3
we have queen to h2 going after this
pawn here but now g5 defending it with
bishop to g2 and now knight to e5 so
really just piling up on that black king
we have rook beat to b1 uh just bringing
all all the firepower to help out with
the defense but now bishop to f7 and now
you already have some ideas of maybe
just capturing this d5 pawn uh but also
if any checks are delivered you can hide
your king behind the bishop so rook beat
the c1 attacking the queen queen d4 and
now rook c to d1 not allowing this
capture of the phone but knight to d31
completely
ignoring this idea rook to d2 adding
another defender to the second rank also
maybe preparing rook to d1 and now while
you could play bishop captures on d5
fabi now abandons this plan and plays
king to g7 first improves the position
of his king a little bit you do not want
to leave it to there on f8 we have h4
and now queen to c4 we have rook f2d1
now putting pressure on the knight and
knight to e5 going after the g4 pawn as
this is now made possible uh since the h
pawn was pushed to h4 we have h captures
on g5 h captures on g5 and now rook to
d4 attacking fabi's queen
queen to c3
so what you play here uh well queen to
g1 there's really not all that much you
can play here now knight captures on g4
we have rook 1 to d2 adding more support
to the second rank and now queen the c8
preparing this wonderful queen to h8 to
check uh which is gonna be deadly so we
have to move the queen queen to a1 now
threatening all sorts of discoveries
here if the rook moves uh since the king
is on g7 but now uh look at this queen
this queen is now gonna pick up this
queen and there's nothing white can do
about it uh queen to h8 to check king to
g1 queen to h2 check king to f1 okay the
h1 square is not available to the queen
but we're going to make it available as
we are going to play rook to f3 with
check and now there's really nothing you
can do here if you move the king of
course then we just start picking up
material so the rook has to be accepted
bishop captures on f3 was played and now
knight to e3 with check forcing the king
away from the g1 square king he won and
now finally queen to g1 with check and
now we pick up the white queen king they
do now queen captures on a1 and it was
in this position and move 59 that uh
alexander landerman resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
it's a queen knight and bishop against
two rooks and bishop of course
completely losing for white uh the past
pawns are also here so
uh not not even uh possible to to try
and defend this uh what does this mean
for the standings well now the leaders
are fabi corrupted leaders now the
leaders are uh samuel savion wesley so
and fabiana corona and there is one more
round to go uh in the usgs championship
2021 we'll see if uh
what can happen anything can still
happen because um
uh well
for example ray robson who is trailing
by half a point is playing against
wesley so so if he beats wesley then
even he could still win the tournament
and uh well there's simply too much to
speculate so we're gonna see what
happens in the final round and
did fabi just make the the comeback of
the year or or or will someone else uh
take the lead like samuel 7 who was
leading from from day one basically or
or maybe even wesley so who also nicely
joined the leader some sometimes during
the first half of the tournament
uh but yeah that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it really a crushing
crushing uh uh victory for fabi he
really had uh
like there were many moments where fabi
could just go for the absolute strongest
move but the absolute strongest move
only yields the draw so you have to play
a bit of a weaker move that gives your
opponent chances but then again not too
many chances but you know
like i said there was this moment where
uh his opponent had the option of
playing g5 and this is something but
this is such an insane brilliancy that
if your opponent finds this then it's
not it's really not a problem if you if
you lose uh but this uh
you have to create
imbalances in the position and allow uh
for brilliancies like these to exist in
order to you know find winning chances
for yourself
uh but yeah okay once again hope you
guys enjoyed this uh i would like to
wish uh a very happy birthday to
zugswong uh and a very happy birthday to
dhanush i hope you guys have uh
an excellent day filled with chess and
joy and i would like to thank jonathan
durock uh charles curran and dave david
farney for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the final
round of the usgs championship checking
up on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
story about a bit of a longer video we
had a lot to cover